well the flag at the White House was
lowered to half-staff overnight but
President Trump and First Lady Melania
Trump are mourning the death of George
HW Bush from abroad major Garrett is
traveling with the president at the g20
summit in Buenos Aires major good
morning to you good morning there's
really no way around it during the 2016
campaign then candidate Donald Trump and
former President George HW Bush didn't
get along but this morning nothing but
kind and complimentary words about Bush
from President Trump Bush an exemplar of
establishment republicanism that then
candidate Trump in 2016 ran so
successfully and aggressively against
writing this morning about a few minutes
after 6:00 a.m. Eastern Time on Twitter
President Trump said the former
president led a beautiful successful and
long life adding this note of personal
observation quote whenever I was with
him I saw his absolute joy for life and
true pride in his family his
accomplishments were great from
beginning to end he was a truly
wonderful man and will be missed by all
that tweet builds on a statement
released earlier by the White House
which read in part with sound judgment
common sense an unflappable leadership
President Bush guided our nation and the
world to a peaceful and victorious
conclusion of the Cold War as president
he set the stage for decades of
prosperity that have followed and
through all that he accomplished he
remained humble following the quiet call
to service that gave him a clear sense
of direction Dana back to you New York
major Garrett and again major we know
you're with the president there and when
oh sorry so we'll check in with you in
just a few minutes